اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه 14
فلسطينيا في انحاء متفرقه من الضفات
الغربيه ليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم وقال
نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان حالات الاعتقال
تجاوزت منذ مطلع العام
2100 حاله اعتقال في صفوف الفلسطينيين من
جانب اخر يعم الاضراب الشامل والحداد كافه
مناحي الحياه في مدينه اريحا تمديدا
بامتياكات الاحتلال وحدادا على الشهيد
محمود حمدان الذي قتلته قواته الاحتلال في
ارحاب الى اريحا تنضم الينا من هناك
مباشره مراسلتنا نجوان سمري نجوان ضعيف
الفعاليات في اريحا ان كان الحداد او
الاضراب
نعم بالفعل مدينه اريحا تشهد اضرابا عاما
يشيل كافه مناحي الحياه اضراب تجاري اضراب
في مؤسسات التعليم وذلك حدادا على الشهيد
الشاب محمود حمدان الذي قتلته قوات
الاحتلال يوم امس باطلاق النار مباشره
عليه خلال تواجده بالقرب من البيت الذي تم
محاصرته يوم امس من قبل قوات الاحتلال في
مخيم عقبه جبر المحازي
لهذه المنطقه او في داخل مدينه اريحا
بحسب شهود عيان كان يستقل دراجه ناريه وتم
اطلاق النار مباشره عليه من قبل قوات
الاحتلال بعدها ولدها محاوله طواقم
الاسعاف الفلسطينيه تقديم الاسعاف
والانعاش له اختطفته قوات الاحتلال
واعتقلته وهو مصاب بحاله حرج منع التقديم
العلاج له وبعد ساعات تم تبليغ الاداره
المدنيه هيئه شؤون الاداره المدنيه
الفلسطينيه بانه استشهد في طبيعه الحال ما
زال الشهيد محتجزا لدى سلطات الاحتلال ومن
غير المعلوم متى سيتم تسليمه ليتم تشييعه
هذا حصل يوم امس امس اثناء العمليه
العسكريه التي نفذها
الاحتلال بمشاركه عده وحدات في الجيش
الاسرائيلي وقوات المستعربين وقوات حرس
الحدود والمخابرات الاسرائيليه بناء على
ما قاله بيان صادر عن الناطق العسكري باسم
قوات الاحتلال معلومات استخباراتيه وصلت
عن مكان وجود المشتبه بهم بتنفيذ عمليه
اطلاق النار في منطقه قريبه من مدينه
اريحا اسفلت عن مقتل احد الاسرائيليين قبل
بضعه
ايام هذه العمليه نفذت يوم امس في وضح
النهار تم اعتقال سته فلسطينيين خلالها
كان الشهيد حمدان من بينهم وايضا
اصيب ثلاثه فلسطينيين خلال هذه العمليه
هذا يحدث في بعد ان تم محاصره مدينه اريحا
والمخيمات التي بها مخيم عقبه جبر ومخيم
عين السلطان لعده ايام وهذا يتكرر بين
الحين والاخر ان يتم محاصره المدينه
بالكامل بحيث يمنع السكان من الخروج في
حال قامت قوات الاحتلال بعمليات بحث
وتمشيط عمن تشتبه بهم بتنفيذ عمليه في
المقابل شنت قوات الاحتلال حملات اعتقال
في مناطق مختلفه في الضفه الغربيه تركزت
في مدينه القدس في بلده العيزريه وايضا في
سلوان 14 معتقلا كان هناك ايضا احد
المعتقلين من مدينه جنين وعمليا
هناك ما زالت عمليات بحث وتمشيط واسعه في
منطقه حواره والقرى جنوبي مدينه نابلس
بحثا ايضا عما تشتبه بهم سلطات الاحتلال
بتنفيذ عمليه يوم الاحد الماضي في حواره
شكرا لك نجوان سمري مراسلتنا من اريحا
سنكون معك في متابعه كل جديد